sollte keine ahnung was glaubt
willkommen beim neuen video
um ehrlich zu sein schule kann ja schon
oftmals schule kann ja schon schule ist
ja schon langweilig und ich muss dazu
sagen ich habe schon ganz lange kein
video mehr gemacht wo es um schule ging
ich meine wieso nicht als ob ich einfach
mal ein bisschen nachgedacht und habe
mir so für euch meine ganz persönlichen
live hacks überlege ich persönlich meine
schulalltag jeden tag über stehe okay
manchmal gehe ich auch nicht hin aber
falls ich will gar nicht angelaufen wir
fangen an mit meinen persönlich besten
live acts der welt und los gehts und
zwar kennt ihr das erste doch bestimmt
anis steht auf ist es halb sieben bei
mir jetzt erst finde verachten aber bei
den meisten halb sieben und es geht
erstmal nichts wenn man so müde ist dann
kann ich euch nur einen tipp geben ihr
müsst wirklich direkt was trinken also
klar man kann einfach wasser trinken
aber ich nehme mal jeweils die ist
zucker drin da bin ich direkt so war
also so richtig wach auch nicht aber ich
bin auf jeden fall zehn mal wacher als
vorher das bringt auf jeden fall so
richtig schwung in den körper und ihr
seid direkt viel besser gelaunt es sei
denn ihr schreibt machte dann bringt
selbst das nicht
okay leute kommen wir zu live act okay
das ist kein richtiger heck aber ja okay
ich verstehe da manche nicht also live
act nummer zwei und zwar ist es ja so
schule ist echt langweilig aber ich bin
man kann sich das doch um so viel
langweiliger gestalten wenn man einfach
in jedem unter richter sitzt und nix
sagt da kann ich wirklich so viele leute
die sitzende einfach und sagen nichts du
weißt gar nicht dass sie existieren und
das beste ist manchmal noch die wissen
die antwort aber die trauen sich einfach
nicht und da denke ich mir dann leute
selbst wenn das fach noch so
uninteressant ist und euch überhaupt
nicht juckt ihr müsst trotzdem einfach
mitmachen weil dann geht die zeit auch
schnell darum selbst wenn ihr kein
planer bei mir gibt's auch fächer ich
weiß da verstehe ich einfach so
vielleicht 10 stellt einfach fragen oder
irgendwas dann kriegt er wenigstens eine
vernünftige note und die zeit geht
schneller rum ob fink noch mal drei das
mach ich meistens wenn ich für der
klausur lernen muss und zum beispiel
jetzt gerade matte dran ist und ich will
dich gerade überhaupt nicht weiter komme
dann steht einfach auf anstatt da sitzen
zu bleiben ich mache dann immer so
folgendes heute keine ahnung
ach egal
ich glaube ich hab's ja wenn jetzt nicht
ein tolles zeit zum fan hab dann keine
ahnung und guckt aus dem fenster oder
macht sonst was aber was ganz wichtig
ist ihr müsst dabei immer an das thema
denken immer wirklich nach einer lösung
suchen weil dann fällt einem das
vielleicht ein
das ist besser anstatt zu sitzen also
ist bei mir zumindest du okay leute
kommen wir zu einem live-act nummer vier
den wirklich eigentlich nur ich also
klar es gibt auch ein paar andere leute
das machen aber ihr kennt doch bestimmt
diese standard frage von wirklich 80
prozent der lehrer so ihr lieben passt
auf was haben wir denn letztes mal alles
gemacht
alex harvey wärst du mit dir hier bitte
wir haben hier war die expansion der
interaktive rosa gesprochen welche in
warza proportionalität zur
intellektuellen kapazität des
kultivieren ergonomisch steht weg sagt
super so da könnt ihr euch alle band
beispiel am alex nehmen ihr seid alles
die größten nichtskönner ihr könnt gar
nichts er kann wenigstens was ich bin
auch schon wieder weg ich würde niemals
wissen was wir gestern gemacht haben es
sei denn ich guck mal ganz kurz vorher
in die mappe das dauert 30 sekunden und
dann weiß man dass hat direkt für eine
positive bewertung gesorgt und ist doch
eigentlich was cooles deswegen gucken
euro ab okay leute und mein letzter live
aid nummer fünf nicht 10.5 wenn ihr
wirklich genauso gerne liest wie ich
also nicht aber jetzt zum beispiel für
den deutschland durch irgendein buch
lesen müsste das 300 400 meinetwegen
auch 800 seiten hat es gibt wirklich so
viele internetseiten kann man sich das
komplette buch als hörbuch anhören ihr
müsst nichts machen außer zu hören ich
meine das kann jeder eigentlich aber ich
habe so kein trockener stoff nicht nur
100 seiten 11 428 panamera moment
hier ist es ja das war's jetzt erstmal
mit dem video aber stopp noch nicht
wegschalten falls euch der letzte live
hacking ist wirklich noch so brennend
interessiert so welche seiten gibt's den
leid ich habe euch einfach mal ein link
und in die video beschreibung gepackt
das nennt sich audio bilder könnt ihr
euch einfach mal so für 30 tage
kostenlos anmelden und das testen blabla
also klick darauf und leute es hilft
wirklich quadratmeter und jahr an sonst
würde ich sagen snapshot instagram war
alles an ihr könnt nicht gerne
abonnieren danke für was weiß ich wie
viel es geht voll ab grad mit dem bussi
links jetzt auch weiter mit meinem
letzten video könnt ihr gern noch mal
vorbeischauen und wir sehen uns dann am
nächsten dienstag 30